I'm going to talk to you today about
some recent work I've been doing with
Ryan Rogers on optimality and local the
differential private algorithms and so
using ideas from communication
complexities so brief outline I'll just
sort of talk a little bit about what I
mean when I say the local model of
privacy I'll talk about sort of how
we're going to think about interactivity
or sort of number of rounds of
communication or something like that
that we do in private algorithms and
maybe some weakening that we do from
standard differential private difference
in private schemes
after that I'll talk about sort of how
everything reduces to communication
complexity and then I will present a
private analog of what's known as a
squads method which is a standard
technique in statistics for proving
lower bounds and then at the end I will
give examples sort of time permitting
well I'm gonna get to the examples
because those are what's interesting
okay so that's the big picture and and
so the setting that we're going to be
working in is the local model of privacy
so what does that mean that means that
an individual has data individual I has
data X I and that there is some kind of
what all what I will use the word
channel because I sit in an electrical
engineering department so I've been
picking up new words so we have a
channel Q which I'll write cube given X
I which releases CI where Zi is going to
be some kind of private analog of X I
okay and and I'll be a little bit more
precise about what I mean when I talk
about privacy okay and so the big
question in this talk is how do we know
do we know if a channel Q is optimal
okay so that's what I'm gonna try to
what I mean by channel I mean a regular
conditional probability from a space X
to a space Z or a Markov kernel for just
something that takes in an X and spits
out something else
I know we're a randomized algorithm you
know a measurable function of X that for
every X is a probability distribution G
pops out that's that's all it is and
there's some noise okay but but but I
wanna I'm going to try to sort of give a
fairly general approach to these lower
bounds and what what I'm gonna do is
think about a sort of a communication
scheme whereby we're going to interact
with individuals X I and they're going
to release private versions of their
data repeatedly okay so so the
communication scheme here is going to be
the following or sort of the interaction
model that we're going to use basically
there's going to be a series of rounds
which I will always index by time T so T
equals 1 2 3 dots a up to some time
capital T and then each round
in each round an individual I releases
some private version
the sub I superscript T so I will always
enjoy yeah I will always index
individual T always into the indexes
time so release it's a private CIT
that can depend on the past that may
depend on the past okay and and so the
way I'm going to think about this is the
is kind of a blackboard model of
communication and so I'm going to draw a
picture that I think makes everything as
clear as I can possibly make it so I
have X 1 X 2 X 3 dot dot say there are
and individuals then we have round 1
individual releases individual one
releases Z 1 1 which may be private in
some way then individual two releases Z
2 1 which the way he or she releases
this may depend on the past individual 3
is going to release Z 3 1 which may also
depend on the past and then all the way
up to individual n is going to release Z
N 1 which of course may also depend on
everything in the past okay so that
would be one round but then after the
round finishes we're going to just sort
of encode everything in some blackboard
which I'll call B for a blackboard so
this is our blackboard blackboard and
everybody's data gets everybody's
private data gets dumped into that and
then we can go back in run the scheme
again so we can just repeat this so then
around - I've got z1 2 from x1 I've got
z2 - from x2 which again may depend on
the past the c32 we're gonna have a lot
of arrows here and all the way out to z
+ 2 which made the pact oops sorry
that guy which may depend on everything
from the past and it may also depend on
the blackboard and whatever is on the
blackboard ok and then we write
everything again to the blackboard at
round 2 would you always have the
individual
on the same order I do but it doesn't
matter because you can imagine you know
I could have n rounds and I can just
permute an in round like 73 you know
only individual two talks around 170 for
individual 74 talk whatever you know so
so that doesn't actually matter okay but
it's a I mean we yeah we should verify
that that's true but that is that is
what happens and then we can kind of
repeat this so is that and and this will
continue on until we're done is the sort
of communication scheme clear for what
we're what we're doing here these just
all disease what's that what do you mean
in code it's just this it's just like
it's just the collection of them but
everybody gets to read it so I'm just
gonna use it as a convenient notation
because indexing all of these is gonna
get ugly so B is just a blackboard and
at the end it has everything or you can
in in communication complexity you call
this a transcript or something like this
if your of your whole protocol okay well
I haven't written down what I'm gonna
solve it all yet so I'm not trying I
mean I have no problem yet so I yeah so
there's no I got lots of problems but
but not in this talk yet okay so so is
that is this sort of scheme by which
we're gonna be communicating is clear
okay okay so so so then now we're gonna
say okay there's a few things we're
gonna do so what we're gonna assume so
it so I said we're going to do things
with privacy so we're gonna make some
kind of privacy assumption here in the
assumption I'm gonna make is that what
I'll call KL privacy which is almost the
weakest form of privacy I know I'll talk
about a slight extension maybe so assume
assumption
we're gonna say that each channel or
release say CIT is epsilon I t KL
private and what I mean by that is the
following I mean that the KL divergence
between say I'm gonna just write it as Q
of Z I T given X I and everything in the
past before say everything before this
point in time so I'm going to condition
on individual I and then everything that
could have come before it so that is Z 1
up to I minus 1 in ROM T and all of the
previous blackboards BT minus 1 the KL
divergence between this and I'm sorry I
ran out of space but this given X I
prime so if an individual eye changes
his or her data but then of course all
the past communications are the same
this is always going to be less than
Epsilon i T okay so the KL version so
this is a week this is weaker than
basically every form of you know Randy
privacy differential privacy what else
is there concentrated DP the only one
it's not weaker than this epsilon Delta
but we have extensions to deal with that
kiss - sorry I three that sort of Gail
privacy's weak would like one thing that
could be different here is you could
just ask that the whole transcript is a
differential private function of the
input and that seems potentially weaker
than this so right so I could ask that
the entire transcript be differentially
private but is that I'm not about to
prepare yeah was that it is a natural
felt to compare that definition we don't
want to cheer oh yeah sure so so I'm
gonna tote so I'm trying to work in a
local model right so so everything is
gonna I'm trying to do everything in a
local model of privacy so certainly I
will get some kind of global KL privacy
because I can just sum them up yes
okay directions
no no no no so if I just had central
privacy then the results I'm going to
talk about won't follow at all all but
its did what I'm saying is not central
privacy rights we used you're still
requiring people to communicate you just
that the entire transcript should be
differentially private but I'm not sure
how that's different from sort of just
the release of an algorithm of a global
algorithm is differentially private
there's no central entity there's all
the data to our problems where this
makes a difference sure you're the model
here is assuming that in some sense that
kind of whatever global privacy
guarantee you get is obtained by adding
up parameters across rounds of right
what you imagine proving privacy in a
different way let's say if you define
privacy as the brought up the
transcription be differentially private
right so we could try to do that I'm
okay so an honest you know honest thing
is I don't you know if I say okay I want
to have local privacy I'm not actually
completely sure how to define that in a
more general way than this Aaron Roth
and some of his students and
collaborators sent me a paper like three
days ago that said they had but I
haven't had time to fully understand it
so so so so I'm if we're working in the
local model like like just the pure
local model privacy it's not clear to me
exactly how you would weaken this in
natural ways but may I mean maybe there
is
I honestly don't know this is this is
sort of the most general version I could
come up with like the the previous work
that I'd like I or other folks have done
has typically been in a model where just
there's one round you know you person
one communicate see one person to
communicate see two person three
communicate see three right so at least
we're gonna allow a little more than
that right you know us but but
potentially alternative I'm happy to
have alternatives I just I don't
honestly know how to write them down in
in good ways
you can just say that's the definition
but the transcript yes yeah I was inside
the privacy that and it is in a local
model because everybody is it is a
distributed mom it's bright yet
conditioned on the knowledge of
everything except the state of local
state of one participant over the entire
red cone and usually different from the
central model because you can't show
separation so you can you can show
problems that you cannot that you need
much more data to solve be that more
than the central one sure yeah so we
could we could we could do alternatives
if you wanted to you know I'm gonna I'm
gonna write this down as our definition
for now because I think as far as I know
among all the results and local
differential privacy and lower bounds it
is this strongest or sort of the the
weakest whatever you want to call it the
one that's making the fewest assumptions
I'm not 100% confident that but I'm you
know like at least fifty percent
confident you give me a randomized
response mechanism I'll tell you exactly
how confident I am okay so anyway so
this is our thing all right so we have
that this Caliban holds and we're gonna
make the assumption that there exists
some epsilon average which is finite
such that the sum from I equals 1 to N
and the sum over all the rounds T equals
1 to T of the expected privacy
violations that I have is let's do that
is less than the average right there
okay so I'm gonna just say on average
the the total amount of sort of KL stuff
you release is less than what I'm just
gonna call epsilon average okay that's
just some some number all right and
that's is whatever we're gonna write our
lower bounds in terms of oh so I think I
missed something else is up so here
decide that you're conditioning when
every possible value of x ICT is so on
it like epsilon I T is a random variable
right epsilon I T may depend on Z
be and all sorts of things just as long
as an expectation it's pretty small yeah
so again you know that's why again this
gets weirder when I try to do it in some
yeah I don't know like to compare them
me neither
that's why I'm not gonna do it okay so
so so this is this is our definition or
assumption or whatever you want to call
it it is it is it is what it's going to
be okay so let me give some intuition
for what you should expect here in terms
of lower bounds because let me give some
intuition for what we should expect in
terms of lower bounds because I think
the intuition actually makes crystal
clear everything we're gonna do and then
everything else is just sort of
mathematical wiggling around until we
make it true okay and so let's let's try
to get some intuition so intuition what
should we expect from any lower bound in
the local model so let's say I wish to
estimate just a mean the mean of a
d-dimensional vector will say X taking
values in plus minus 1 to the D okay so
I just have a vector in every coordinate
at least marginally every coordinate is
going to be some kind of Berlin
Bernoulli thing right okay
so how many bits does it take to
describe this vector it takes D bits
right
so it takes D bits to describe some X in
plus minus 1 to the D that's that's
pretty clear by just til you've looked
there's some arbitrary vector in n plus
minus 1 to the D it's gonna take D bits
okay but now if we had just let's think
about just a pure epsilon DP algorithm
so if Z given X is pure epsilon DP then
that means that the likelihood ratio of
Q of Z given
X divided by Q of Z given X prime is of
course less than either the epsilon
right I mean it seems I mean that's the
definition right and so if you think
about this okay so so from sort of an
information theoretic perspective or
whatever the number of bits I'm actually
going to be able allowed to describe
about this thing you know how much can I
change it from all ones to all minus
ones it's basically epsilon bits that's
how much the likelihood ratio can change
it's just it's sort of a little so so I
can describe at most sort of epsilon
bits of a vector X in plus minus one to
the D right using a differential private
channel this is assuming epsilon is like
order one or bigger even okay and so
once we have that then sort of the X and
if I were to actually try to estimate
the mean of a vector if I told you
estimate the mean of a d-dimensional
vector I'm gonna let you see only
epsilon bits of every observation chosen
at random then you would expect that
you'd have some penalty that scale sort
of like the dimension divided by the
number of bits you get to observe so
expected penalty in estimation of this
quantity say X should be something like
dimension divided by number of bits
which is equal to D on Epsilon
right so if I could so so so what am I
saying because you know it did the
intuition is I'm only seeing like for
any given vector any individuals vector
I'm seeing only a fraction epsilon over
D of the sort of information in it right
I get to observe I observe only epsilon
over D fraction of individuals data
all right so that's kind of the up the
intuition and then so if you think you
know any epsilon any differentially
private release or any locally
differentially private release we should
expect penalties essentially for any
epsilon you choose I don't care if it's
1 or 4 or you could choose epsilon
equals the dimension which maybe some of
you have some disagreements with but I
don't know so let's see yeah you're
totally right so let's suppose let's
suppose for this little heuristic that
epsilon is bigger than or equal to the
same one ish okay and and you're right
there's this weird thing that happens at
the threshold of one where you go from
epsilon 2 epsilon squared and and I mean
so what that would mean is that these
epsilon I T's would just be epsilon
squared okay so you should but I'm not
gonna worry I'm not gonna worry about
that for now but this so so think of
this I know I think this is pretty
reasonable intuition you know you're the
most you're gonna be able to describe
any given vector is sort of by
describing about epsilon over D of its
bits roughly and then and then once
we've got that then we're we're
basically in business for proving lower
bounds so let's um we check my time so
let's uh let's now describe the actual
framework for proving lower bounds and
optimality results that we're doing and
then we will go from there
excuse me all right so there's a there's
sort of a long line of literature on
well maybe not that long but but there's
a been a nice line of literature on
communication complexity and statistical
estimation sort of the combination of
this and just to give a little bit of
credit so with collaborators with my
advisors and and you can John who's now
somewhere I think this is it a startup
that it got acquired by Microsoft anyway
he's a bit peripatetic hard to keep
track of so we we studied just sort of
generic statistical estimation under
information constraints in fairly simple
communication models and then a couple
of works by Garg MA and when in 2014 and
then this was extended by Braverman
garde ma when and Woodruff and I think
this was 2016 but I'm not sure I might
have been off by one here on the years
but these guys so so we had this kind of
obtuse terrible way of trying to
understand estimation under information
constraints and these guys really
extended it and and and made it a very
made a very elegant approach to
basically saying like you know optimal
rates for estimation
when you have constraints when you
constrain basically the communication or
the mutual Shannon information between
an individual excise data and the actual
communicated variables alright so they
built so between these three papers
really really nailed down I think very
in a really elegant way in the this
favor by Braverman guardman
when in Woodruff really showed how to
understand optimal rates for estimation
when you constrain oopsie when you
constrain the mutual information you're
releasing about your variables right so
so let's so let me let me know describe
what I mean when I say optimality so
we're gonna work so so Adam introduced
minimax risk which was a great thing
because that means I can write it
reasonably quickly so thanks Adam for
pumping up the crowd right there yeah
you like the opening act is that yeah
I've never actually been to a concert so
I don't know how this works
well classical concerts but those are
they don't have opening act on those so
I don't really understand it anyway so
so definition so this is gonna be
minimax risk
under some kind of privacy and straight
we're going to let Q be that channel
really any collection of K or a
communication scheme under our model
which I've just erased okay and let's
let script P be a collection of
distributions so this is any collection
of distributions distributions on a
space script X and we're going to let
theta be some parameter of interest okay
and what this could be this could be
anything but basically it's just a
function of your distribution generating
your data it's just some function of the
distribution say like the mean of your
data of your data generating
distribution or the variance or the
minimizer of some convex loss or
anything okay so it's just some
parameter of interest and we're going to
let L which is going to map our
parameter space into our plus B a loss
function okay so this is this is the
whole shebang the minimax risk
is then I'll write it as script n sorry
script M of the parameter applied to our
set of distributions with loss L and
channel Q is defined to be equal to the
infimum over all possible estimators of
the supremum over all distributions in
my space and distributions of the
expected loss will write this this way
of theta hat oopsie
sorry about that of the loss of theta
hat I'm gonna just write it as bold Zi
for beta of P okay all right so that's
the minimax risk I don't really know a
better way to write this so this is
where x1 through xn are all iid from P
and then Z is drawn according to your
whole channel given all the data okay so
you're gonna pass I mean so it so you
should think of Q as being any any set
of channels that satisfy something like
this kind of guarantee okay and so what
we're going to be asking is what is if
I'm going to measure the performance of
a particular estimator by its worst
performance over my whole function class
or sorry my whole class of distributions
this is what we've got so we're looking
for the best estimator where I measure
the quality of an estimator by its
worst-case expected loss or expected
error all right okay any questions about
the definition this is minimax risk cool
all right so now the the way we approve
lower bounds on the minimax risk there
are a lot of techniques but typically
what one does is one basically does
what's called a reduction of estimation
to testing and this is sort of a
classical idea from the 60s and 70s in
the statistics literature but basically
what you say is I'm going to embed a
bunch of sort of discrete problems in my
in my in my distribution set if I can
estimate well then I can identify which
discrete problem I had originally
started that okay so that's the game so
let's let's make this a tiny bit more
formal so this is so I'm going to use
what's known as a swats method which is
basically and this is I think 83 it's
basically the idea is we're going to
embed our problem into it finding a
corner of the hypercube or collecting
enough data to estimate a corner of a
hypercube where we're getting data from
okay so we're going to index our
distributions P by a hypercube and I
will use script V equals plus minus 1 to
the D so we've got this hypercube and
I'm going to for any vector V in script
V we're going to let theta sub B equals
the parameter associated with
distribution P V okay so so to each
corner of my hypercube I've got a
parameter associate and a distribution
all right
so then we say that these parameters the
parameters
theta V R Delta separated for the
Hamming metric
if excuse me for all for any parameter
theta in we're gonna have everything
being Hardy sorry I should have been a
bit clear about that if for every
parameter theta in Rd we might have the
loss of theta when the if I tried to
guess theta when the true answer was
theta sort of at whatever quarter the
hypercube I have is greater than or
equal to Delta times the sum from J
equals 1 to D of the indicator that I
have the incorrect sign so I'm not equal
to J ok and so somehow the picture of
this is that the intuition always say it
in words the intuition is that if I
could estimate this parameter very well
then I could develop some kind of test
that would tell me hey what corner of
the hypercube is your data coming from
ok so that's the that's kind of the the
idea here is that you know if I've got
my if I've got my hypercube here so I
here are my four corners of the
hypercube if I had an estimator that was
sort of accurate to within some small
distance of a corner then I could tell
you that the data was coming from that
corner right or if I had an estimator
that was accurate to this radius I could
tell you that the data was coming from
this corner so I can now I could test
where my data is coming from so I'm
gonna I'm gonna basically play a game
where nature is gonna choose an index
from the hypercube and hand me data from
it and then I have to decide ok what's
the corner of the hypercube that is
generating this data all right
okay so that's a this is what I mean
when I say my parameters are well
separated for the Hamming metric and
then with this with this definition we
have a swats method
so that's what's meant that says the
following so we have the following lemma
which is the actual version of it that's
one with some minor extensions to make
it usable for us so let's let nature
choose V in plus minus 1 to the D the
uniformly at random so nature is gonna
choose some random vector from a corner
of the hypercube fix any random corner
all right
and then conditional on on V equals
little V I'm going to draw a data X
according to P V and then I'm going to
generate my Z you know generate Z from
my channel whatever given thanks okay so
the picture I mean just the Markov chain
is V goes to Z no sorry V goes to X goes
to Z all right so V gets generated X is
generated Z is generated then we're
going to let blackboard bold P plus
minus J be the marginal distribution
distribution of Z conditional on BJ that
is the J's coordinate all I care about
is the J's coordinate being equal to
plus or minus 1 okay then we have the
following lower bound then we see that
the minimax risk this is I'm gonna not
write the whole thing but the minimax
risk for this particular channel is
lower bounded by Delta over 2 times the
sum from J equals 1 up to D of the
infimum over all possible estimators the
hat of the probability that V hat J of Z
is not equal to AJ which is also equal
to Delta over 2 times the sum from J
equals 1 up to D of 1 minus the total
variation distance between these
marginal
distributions okay
and by Koshi Schwartz this is greater
than D times Delta over two times the
quantity one minus square root one on D
times the sum from J equals 1 up to D of
P plus J minus P minus J DV squared okay
all right so what's gonna happen now so
the intuition for what I'm gonna show or
what we can show is basically that by
having the data have to go through this
private channel right here you know so
normally you would you know in classical
statistics there's no privacy you know
nature chooses some random state of the
world I get to observe X as I estimate
the end right so now we've kind of
elaborated this model and we have this Z
tacked on to the end and that's all we
get to observe because we're private
right and so intuitively and we'll make
this rigorous momentarily what's gonna
happen is that these distributions are
gonna get smooshed a lot closer together
because the data has to go through this
channel and if I sort of smooshing
things together this is gonna make these
probabilities this this distance
extremely small which is going to make
your error or your estimation error
extremely large because you're gonna
have 1 minus some very small quantities
it's just gonna be one basically we're
not gonna be able to test what corner of
the hypercube the data actually came
from okay so that's the intuition for
what's gonna happen any
questions on that all right
okay so uh let's do this so to make this
rigorous I'm gonna need to need a notion
of what's known as a strong data
processing inequality all right so let's
let's come up with a definition let's
let I'm gonna change notation a tiny bit
just to make our lives easier because I
don't want us to get confused when I'm
doing one-dimensional things versus
d-dimensional things so we're gonna have
you go for we're gonna have a Markov
chain from u to X to Z and now U is
going to just be a uniform random
variable U is going to be in just plus
or minus 1 ok so U is just plus or minus
1 it's a binary random variable so we
say that the strong data processing
constant data processing will see a
strong data processing constant and I'll
call this the SDP constant not the semi
definite programming constant I got
nothing that's what it is
so SDP strong data processing inequality
today is beta P 1 from P minus 1 is
defined to be equal to
oh it's sorry well I'll describe this in
a minute the infimum over all beta less
than or equal to 1 such that the mutual
information between U and Z is less than
or equal to beta times the information
between X and Z for all X goes to Z so
for all sampling schemes from X to Z ok
and here basically X is distributed
according to P u when u equals little
you in plus minus 1
okay so it's basically we're asking okay
I have this channel from you 2x then I
have a strong data processing inequality
if there's some value beta which is
strictly less than one so that the
information that no matter what channel
I have from X to Z the information that
sorry that Z carries about you Z carries
about you is less by some constant
factor than the information he carries
about X okay
this is just this is just a definition
but the the the the remarkable thing is
there's this beautiful theorem by sorry
by braverman Garg MA when and Woodruff
which shows how we can use these ideas
to prove lower bounds and communication
complexity okay and what we do is we
extend this idea into these private
scenarios with a little bit more wiggle
wiggle around to to leverage these
things so let me describe the theorem
and then we'll show how we can use it to
actually prove our lower bounds okay so
far so good okay yeah okay so so what
we're gonna have to do I'm going to make
the following additional assumption
assume that my data vectors X are drawn
from a product distribution and why that
is important I will say momentarily that
is for V equals little V in plus minus 1
X is drawn according to P V 1 Cross P V
2 cross dot dot cross P the deep just to
say that X has independent coordinates
so my data vectors X have to have
independent coordinates alright so
conditional on whatever corner of my
hyper cube I'm in I generate each in
each coordinate of X independently at
random okay so why I mean intuitively
why do I need this well because we're
doing communication complexity if the
coordinates of X were correlated then of
course I can send things with much much
smaller communication right I had you a
D dimensional vector
tell you hey this is d dimensions but
all of its coordinates are either all
ones or all minus ones I bet you guys
can figure out a way to send that with
fewer than D bits right yeah okay I
guess so that's good
we're in agreement that if things are
infinitely correlated we can we can
communicate with bus information okay
and what you got to start somewhere
right it said this is the story of the
talk you start somewhere and then you
try to get everybody incensed at you you
take the least controversial thing you
can you try to make it as controversial
as possible so that everyone gets mad at
you without you get interesting
conversations okay so so this is our
setting but anyway so under this under
this setting so we have the following
result which is the sort of main
technical tool that I am going to use so
we have the following theorem and this
is due both to Ryan and me and then it's
sort of also builds extremely strongly
off of this paper by Braverman at all
okay so let's assume that for each J in
one to D I have the Markov chain so V
sub J goes to X I J that is the J eighth
coordinate of my data vectors X so these
are just D dimensional vectors so I have
this guy satisfies this has an S dpi
strong data processing inequality with
beta of P plus 1 from P minus 1 is equal
to beta less than 1 ok so we actually
satisfy these strong data processing
inequality so I'll give an example
showing how we can these actually often
hold in enrollment Cheerilee but then
and additionally that the log likelihood
ratio between P 1 and P minus 1
is founded all right DP is less than
some P then the mutual information I'm
sorry then one on D times the sum from J
equals 1 up to D of the total variation
distances which is to say the
probability of errors in my little tests
of where my data is actually coming from
this is upper bounded by 7 sorry
7 times that be great if it just stopped
there wouldn't it it's actually upper
bounded by 1 so that would be a pretty
shitty upper bound but it was I'm not
supposed to say those words anymore I
have children this divided by D times
beta times the actual mutual information
between the individual data all right
the the individuals data and the entire
released transcript of all of the random
variables given this random vector P
okay so so basically what you should be
thinking is if this beta is small so we
have this kind of strong contraction
then the sort of distance on my ability
to test between whether I have plus J or
minus J is going to get a lot smaller
and we can control this mutual
information using our privacy guarantees
okay and that's exactly what we're going
to have so let me let me now give a
lemma and an example where we prove yeah
the tell me sorry this Robin had the
version with Hellinger distance is this
difference no no no no they they yeah so
it's a Hollinger distance is equivalent
to variation distance so they so okay so
so the main so it's okay so I'm writing
this this way basically where we ended
up building sort of an analog glass well
it's math out of this that wasn't quite
exactly how they were doing their
reductions so we can we can talk off
line I mean I mean you should you know
that it's like I mean really I I really
do want to give like there there's a
reason their name is in this theorem
statement because they really did almost
all the heavy lifting to make this
happen you know and we had some minor
extensions to let it work well with us
what's method and embeddings and the
hypercube in general losses that weren't
quite present in the way they did it
that's all
they then so they had a slightly
different formulation with min
information and some other stuff that
just it made it a little harder for us
to apply it in the scenarios we were
thinking of what's the upper bound of
the divergence between P 1 and P minus 1
plus they're equal to weigh sorry uh
where are we right here that this guy
yeah what's the B sorry
there's some constant B my like yeah
just the likely ratio is bounded from
the incoming stuff that's all that's it
okay so then we have this but but let me
give a lemma and then I'll do an example
and then we can call it a day that sound
sound good and then we'll my I mean my
handwriting may not be good so this is
supposed to be a B okay we're good yeah
so one over the dimension beta is the
contraction think of B being one it's
like row
what I haven't took an extra 15 I'm not
gonna I'm not gonna go pack I got I got
five more minutes okay
I do want everybody to get to the break
but let me let me at least get to a
punchline here and so we can prove a
lower bound for Bernoulli estimation
yeah I know it's super exciting it
extends to like general convex
optimization but that's annoying to deal
with okay all right so then the
corollary is under our privacy
definition with KL r KL privacy
definition we have that this sum one on
D times the sum from J equals 1 up to D
P plus J from P minus J variation
distance is less than or equal to again
7 e to the B plus 1 divided by the
dimension times beta and times epsilon
average so the average KL release of the
information about people right okay so
let me do now a sort of example and with
this we will finish up ok so let me give
let me give a concrete case where this
holds with a very particular constant
and then we'll use that to prove a lower
bound so suppose that I have a channel u
goes to X goes to Z where again U is
going to be plus minus 1 where log DP u
over DP of - you DV 1 well you over - u
is less than or equal to some alpha ok
so I have a bounded likelihood ratio on
this channel that is to say X given u
equals little U is distributed according
to P you
where you is in plus minus one then the
strong data processing inequality
between these if less than or equal to
let me make sure I get this right two
times e to the Alpha minus one okay so
if you have a bounded likelihood ratio
where this alpha is reasonably small
then you get that this is less than
basically alpha squared okay so this is
equals o alpha squared if alpha is small
okay so let's suppose we have a
Bernoulli so let's do D dimensional
Bernoulli a situation okay and so in
particular let's let P plus -1 equal to
a Bernoulli where I have 1 plus or minus
Delta on to where Delta is of course in
0 1 okay then clearly I have a bound of
log likelihood ratio so then I have the
absolute value of log P 1 over P minus 1
is excuse me less than or equal to log 1
plus Delta on 1 minus Delta okay
and if I just substitute that in there
then I'm going to get a strong
data-processing inequality
which will have exactly the types of
terms that we need to make our lives
good so then we get that the information
between you and Z for any channel is
going to be less than or equal to 2
times 1 plus Delta on 1 minus Delta
minus 1 squared times the information
between X and Z which of course is equal
to 8 Delta squared divided by 1 minus
Delta squared times the information
between X and Z which is to say so for
the D dimensional Bernoulli problem ie
the coordinates of X X IJ are drawn
according to a Bernoulli with 1 plus V J
Delta on 2 we have the following minimax
we have the parameters are going to be
just the means theta of PV equals
expectation of X which is going to be
equal to delta x addy in plus minus 1 to
the D okay so we have these just
Bernoulli random variables their
expectations are Delta times V we've
really dumped the thing on the hypercube
then we have separation say in l2 of the
following form theta minus theta the two
norm squared is definitely greater than
or equal to Delta squared times the sum
of the indicators that I got the signs
of my coordinates wrong
okay so anytime you get a coordinate
wrong on this that means you're off on
the wrong side of the hypercube you're
gonna pay Delta squared and applying a
swats method along with this theorem we
get that the following lower bound so
the minimax lower bound for estimating
the mean of a Bernoulli distribution
with D parameters an l2 norm squared
error for any channel satisfying our
epsilon local DP guarantees is greater
than or equal to some numerical constant
C 0 times the dimension times Delta
squared because that's our separation
here times 1 minus this quantity so that
is 1 minus the square root of another
numerical constant C 1 times Delta
squared divided by D times n times
epsilon average amount of KL compromised
so now I just choose Delta so as to
maximize this or equivalently make it so
that I can't test what corner I'm on
just make this a constant so I choose
Delta basically equal to sorry Delta
squared the minimum of one and D on N
and the average privacy released and I'm
going to get the lower bound that this
is greater than equal to C times D times
the minimum of one and D on N and then
the average privacy loss of any
individual okay and so as n goes to
infinity this is equal to big Omega of D
on n that's the standard centralized
rate times D on the average privacy
please
okay so that is it
we have extensions to some of these
results to do a general convex
optimization if you want they're not
extremely more involved in this honestly
you can embed them in estimating things
on hypercubes and then you're done and
you know I think there are as you guys
have already as you guys have already
pointed out there are definitely
questions about what's the right notion
of local privacy in these scenarios and
things like this and I'm happy for
alternative definition stuff like that
but the nice thing is that you know this
applies no matter what privacy release
you use no matter what mechanisms you
use no matter how large epsilon is if
you're crazy like me and you're like
let's make epsilon the dimension because
you feel like it right because you want
to make people unhappy I guess it's fine
the lower bounds still apply so anyway
so thanks for your attention and I'm
happy to take questions during the break